so you're stuck in a dungeon with a
20-sided die and a dragon is keeping you
in the dungeon and the dragon will only
let you out if you can roll a particular
total on the dice
now you get to choose what the total is
so please could you choose me a number
that's bigger than 20. uh all right how
about
42 42 good number okay so then your
challenge is
to roll the die and try to get 42. if
you hit 42 you win you get to leave the
dungeon uh if you don't hit 42 then you
get kept in the dungeon with the dragon
forever
um so let's give it a go I get one go
one go all right let's let's see what we
do all right here we go first roll
that's five five
okay it's a good start you haven't gone
past 42 yet okay
it's also pretty good 21 we're halfway
another 5 and 16 to be good be good
wouldn't it
12.
so now what do you want to win here what
are we going around 21
33.
I think you need another nine to be home
nine more okay of course smaller than
nine would be okay yeah all right
oh six six so we're still still playing
all right three to go come on a three
lucky three come on
ah eleven
I've busted past it yeah past 42 it's a
bit like that game where you have to get
to 21 without going over 42. so
unfortunately the dragon seas that
you've gone past 42 and it's it's game
over
but I think 42 was quite a good pick
because you had lots of lots of outs
along the way uh you didn't you didn't
go out too quickly and there were lots
of possibilities along the way
um I think the natural question is
what's the best number that you could
have picked more than 20 but the best
number the one that's most likely to
come up when you roll the die
it's not even obvious that there is such
a number I suppose maybe they're all
equally good maybe it doesn't matter so
you should just pick 42. what do you
think about that do you think I think
if if such a number exists
it has to be
40 or less 40 or less okay so you want
it so that you could get it in two rolls
yeah but and and it feels like the
highest it could be is double the number
otherwise it feels like it just becomes
arbitrary after you get to double the
highest number yes that's that's the
right intuition that um to start off
with the the effects of
finite size of the die matter really
quite a lot and then in the long run
things even out and we can even be a bit
precise about how things even out So
eventually you're getting large numbers
you picked a target number that was a
billion and three or something
um so after a while you're rolling and
rolling and I guess you're still alive
because you haven't got to a billion and
three yet
um
the die has an average it has an average
number that it that it rolls on average
which over the long run as you're trying
to get to a billion um that's kind of
what your experience is going to be that
the die has an average
um which means that you hit every number
every so often that the probability that
any particular number comes up is one in
the average length of uh skips that you
take when you roll the average of a
20-sided die is 10 and a half I think so
for a very large number like a billion
or something your odds of seeing that
particular number one billion and three
at one in ten and a half which is that
weird mix of being an approximation
while also a weirdly precise number
which is not great odds question can you
do better than that by picking a small
number my answer is yes you can so the
odds that you see a hundreds I'm gonna
write P for probability and 100 for the
probability that you see the number 100.
that's like you chose a three digit
number p100 for the Target well in order
to see 100
think about what the previous number was
and maybe you saw 99 and then you rolled
a one or maybe you saw 98 and then
you're older two or maybe you saw a 97
and then you rolled a three and so on
and so on and so on or maybe you saw uh
80.
and you rolled 20.
um so there's something you can do to
relate this back to the previous numbers
this is a example of something called a
recurrence relation where I don't know
the number that I'm looking for straight
away but I can work it out in terms of
smaller problems to
break down the problem into these
smaller parts there's a bit of work to
do here if I want p100 it's like I have
to keep working backwards through all
these previous numbers for numbers less
than 20 there's also a chance that you
just roll it straight away that there
wasn't any previous role at all you just
got straight in there and rolled it but
you didn't allow that I think that's I
think it's a more fun game if you have
to pick a number more than 20. none of
this cheeky roll it straight away on the
die that's why I made you pick a number
bigger than 20. armed with that
recursion relation you can get a
computer to work out the probabilities
that different numbers come up and the
graph is kind of interesting so the
graph looks like this the probability
that you see certain total of one is
something because you might roll it
straight away the probability that you
see two is a little bit larger because
you might roll it straight away or you
might roll one twice to get your T and
then in a similar madner the
probabilities get larger and larger up
to
20 which is the last number which
benefits from this effect that you could
just roll it straight away 21 isn't so
fortunate 21 you have to make it in two
rolls and this is quite likely that you
blow past 21 on this 20-sided die
probably the hit 21 is down here
somewhere oh really low it's a lot lower
somewhere in between the probabilities
for 1 and 20 on the graph but then
things get a little bit better for a
brief window the next bit of the graph
looks like this
with a sort of arch shape
and at 40 there's a kink in the graph
and then it levels off and at 60 it
Smooths out even more and there's
another wobble in the graph and it
flattens out towards this kind of
long-term probability of one in ten and
a half but the absolute best point is
like you said ready between 20 and 40
there's some Maximum on this on this
graph it turns out that the number 34 is
the best total that you could give to
the Dragon
and I just know that because I've done
the calculations and checked the
probabilities that different numbers
come up if you want to check it you
could roll the die quite a lot and see
which different totals come up I claim
the number 34 comes up more than any
other number bigger than twins did I hit
34 uh 21
33 oh 33 is pretty close so around 34
these numbers are all pretty likely to
come up yeah um so a number around 33 to
35 if I let you pick a couple of numbers
that are near each other some sort of
little interval Maybe here's the target
I'm aiming for plus or minus two then
centering it on 34 is still a good idea
but it gets much more likely if I give
you a little interval that you could hit
if you'd allowed any number though 20 is
the one to pick uh yes any number any
number at all 20 is the most likely to
want to come up on on sums just between
1 and 20 things get more and more likely
as you have more and more ways to make
those numbers plus also the bonus of
maybe rolling them in one and just
getting it straight away on that die so
I guess the the kind of
next question after 20 is really likely
to come up 34 is the next most likely
there's a bit of a random number 34
somewhere between 20 and 40.
um
I suppose the
extension to this question is
what happens if I get stuck in a
different dungeon with a larger Dragon
who owns a larger die with more sides on
it so it goes to a bigger number well
the question the question I've got
before you answer that question is what
if it's what if the dragon has the most
common dye that most people have a
six-sided dice yeah a six-sided die
there's a very similar picture a maximum
between 6 and 12 that you should pick as
a number that's going to come up in your
running total when you're on that
six-sided die in the dungeon of the
Dragon but you want a bigger die bigger
than 20. yeah so there's this kind of
smooth pattern that we get with these
dots on the graph which gets smoother
and smoother the more dots that you have
to get more dots I need more faces on
the die
and the calculations get harder so just
in case you're trapped in a dungeon with
a very large die it'd be good to have a
rule of thumb or some sort of heuristic
about where this is in terms of I don't
know if this is a sweet spot that sweet
spot is somewhere between n
and 2N
this sweet spot for where this kind of
curve of the graph hits its maximum the
best probability that you can pick
um the heuristic or the answer in
general to Leading order is that that
Peak happens at e minus 1 times n where
e is the number 2.7 I guess it comes off
in problems like this a natural log or
whatever they uh yeah the basis of
natural logarithms but then subtract one
and multiply by n so this is a rule of
thumb for where that maximum lies for
very large n which does give you about
34 for the dragon in our original
problem may be weird that that's not a
whole number e is irrational so this is
never a whole number no matter how big
the die is
um but this gives you a good
approximation to where the maximum of
the function is there's some really nice
continuous version of this problem where
you have a die that sort of could roll
any number and it gives us this proper
smooth distribution the one that's kind
of hiding in between the dots
sort of correct way to join the dots and
have this kind of version of the problem
where the dragon wants you to hit some
interval between
some number and some other number
so there's an application of this to
evil numbers an evil number is one where
the decimal expansion of that number
so if you take your favorite number like
Pi or something
3.14159265 and keep going and if you add
up the digits so three plus one plus
four plus one plus five plus nine and
keep going
um if at some point
that equals the number 666 then you say
that your number is evil and bad news Pi
is evil uh the digits add up to 666 at
some point
um at some point
you get 666 Pi is evil and there's some
very similar mathematics you can run to
talk about the probabilities that you
hit any particular Target
um 666 is quite a large number so we're
in that realm of long-term probabilities
and because the digits could be one or
two or three four five six seven eight
nine the average for what the digits
could be I guess I'm ignoring zero but
zeros don't really get you anywhere
closer to your rolling total they just
delay the inevitable the average that
you get when you actually make progress
on your total is this which is the
number five I think because that tops 45
because the average is five that means
that along the way once the numbers are
large you're running total hits roughly
every one number in five it's taking
jumps of about five each time so it hits
roughly every fifth number not exactly
of course it's random but it hits
roughly every fifth number
um which means that unfortunately 20 of
numbers are evil
um one in five twenty percent of them
are evil including things like the
square root of three or the golden ratio
turn up to be evil numbers as well
not not e though I don't know I don't
know if he is evil um we could try and
work it out but we'd need quite a lot of
digits of of e this keeps you busy on a
rainy day you need a lot of decimal
digits
suppose about 100 of them in order to
add them up and then check oh did you
hit exactly 666 or not on your way up so
it's just like the die rolling problem
if you like but with a nine-sided die I
don't know how to make a nine-sided die
but perhaps that's what the what the
digits are doing I like that I like that
Pi's evil we've had a different
definition of evil numbers on number
file before to do with prime numbers but
this is another evil number definition
I've seen a third one as well so there's
another way that people will refer to
evil numbers to do with their binary
expansion as well but I think that's one
for a different number five video to do
you chose 666 because of the you know
the biblical famous Biblical reference I
guess you could come up with any cool
number like 42 42 is again pretty cool
and you could call that a hitchhiker
number is is pi hitchhiker number does
it hit 42 and things like that so well
let's see let's do the graph for um
let's do the graph for adding up numbers
up to nine because 42 is somewhere in
between multiple rules of nine so maybe
it's near a maximum of one of those
maybe it's more likely to come up than
666 in our digits um
let's do the graph I suppose calculate
some probabilities
footnote I maybe didn't mean to have the
three plus at the start
um maybe even numbers just use the
decimal digits I can't remember in my
defense all of this is made up anyway
none of this really none of this really
matters it's not really evil it's not
really evil either way
um you can't call Pie evil the
fractional part of Pi is definitely evil
maybe the three saves it
thanks to brilliant for supporting this
video now you probably know all about
brilliant by now makers of these
fantastic courses and quizzes covering
Math logic data science neural networks
computer programming all sorts of stuff
I've shown you examples like this before
but I don't think I've ever mentioned
how great they are on your phone or
handheld devices
seamless design all the interactive
material it's an absolute Delight
smooth great to look at so you can be
building your skills and knowledge on a
train or on the bus to work just sitting
around on the sofa
now look I'll be honest I can't be
absolutely sure all the people in this
footage are doing brilliant courses but
I like to think that guy is and they
definitely all should be on brilliant
there's so much great stuff on there
they're always adding more material as
well this could be the start of your
path to a new career or maybe just a way
to sharpen your mind go to brilliant.org
number file to start a free 30-day trial
and you'll get 20 off an annual plan
check out the link in the video
description
yeah they must be looking at brilliant
[Music]
lots of things it's a beastly Prime okay
so a beastly Prime is one that has um
666 in it now this one has it in a very
special place right in the middle right
the Obesity Prime is one that has 666 so
for example another beastly Prime is
this one six six one two six six six
nine is a beastly Prime there's a whole
bunch of these as well